[Music]
a few
moments later
[Applause]
the following day raiders we have money
how much it's everything we have sir our
whole harvest was stolen
you have lodging yeah
absolutely good come up and help two
hours later
the following tell stay this is my first
job you can keep the money all of it
i just need this job to get into the
guild
meet me at hangar three five and half an
hour
[Music]
one debt to society later
[Applause]
hit me in the best car and at that range
best car held up
[Music]
and at that range best car held up
uh it's a five-person job i got four
all i need is the ride
and you brought it
[Music]
two very boring minutes later someone
tell me why we'd even need a mandalorian
well apparently they're the greatest
warriors in the galaxy
one eternity later but a great dragon is
too much for me to take on a loan
help me kill it i'll give you the armor
[Music]
12 seconds later
you wanna tell me what's going on
[Music]
the contact wants passage to the system
fine 15 minutes later
[Music]
[Applause]
one pair of pants later
sorry lady i don't understand frog
how many did you eat
just then by sheer coincidence
i can lead you to one of their kind
but first we need your help on our
mission
mission a few inches later
corporate needs you to find the
differences between this picture
and this picture indel has told us there
are at least seven
okay i already see one given okay
they're the same picture
if we could take out that one last base
navarro would be completely safe
we could be a trade anchor for the
entire sector what are we looking at
several bad puns later have you been
taking good care of him
yeah yeah he said yeah
so much later that the old narrator got
tired of waiting and they had to hire
a new one and i'll help you with your
problem
if you see to it that grogu is properly
trained
i'm being torn apart
i want to be free of this pain i know
what i have to do but i don't know if i
have the strength to do it
you